I'm blessed and this work is mostly done
with
sucker and I'll try to give a summary of
the few different things we did to get
this court under control somewhat so I
mean the basic assumptions are extremely
simple it's basically that passwords are
bad and we are all using them and some
people around here I think supposedly
are trying to change that and get other
things instead of passwords to log into
systems now to just see the size of this
monster we're dealing with average user
like recent studies have shown they have
a hundred accounts that's way more than
your parents for but the funny thing is
actually that if you ask them how many
they have initially they say you know I
might have 10 and they ask them list
them and how many social media how many
think and then they realize that their
own estimates are very wrong similarly
for the creation rate we get about 50
new passwords per year I mean this is UK
data but there's no reason to think it's
really different from here and well
you're you mentioned it we are all
familiar with the counterproductive
constraints there's actually very
important work by Laurie Craner and a
few others to try to reverse that trend
because I think if not for her by now we
would have actually Google asking us to
put Sumerian characters in our passwords
now problem with any constraint system
is that you say you know give me a
number give me a special character and
naturally people do one at my password
and it actually sometimes reduces the
reg complexity so that's the state of
password use and because of that
everyone we uses the same password all
the time seventy-five percent of people
we use they're even the strongest ones
people share them all the time 40% of
users do and they lose them all the time
actually that's a very annoying data
that people if you ask them whether they
had to reset their main personal email
password in the past three months about
40 percent say yes
for the bank accounts it's around it's
it's always between 40 and 60 percent
for email banking and professional
passwords and the thing is those are
independent so like on average a user
has reset one-and-a-half passwords over
the past three months of their three
four main passwords so this once again
is UK data so we have a very big scourge
now we have author authentication
methods we mentioned earlier biometrics
and one big problem with that is that
well for the real like traditional
biometrics fingerprints face iris so far
every major development every system
that was deployed has been hacked or
vulnerably has been found within the
first six month and the problem is if
someone steals your password create
another account create another password
changing your iris is slightly more
bothersome now there's so you know
biometrics is non behavioral biometrics
are complicated because they're easily
hackable so far and dangerous long term
behavioral biometrics are interesting
but still not widely used so let's just
forget about biometrics for now because
not mature enough other possibility use
Facebook use Google use all your
neighbors right there just give a key to
your neighbor which you know is fine if
it's one neighbor if your neighbor has
the key to 300 million people you might
start to worry about their power now I
don't like trusting facebook with all my
past
words that depends on you but I think
it's a reasonable assumption that you
might not want to do that all the time
physical devices the oldest hack used to
be if I wanted to hack whatever computer
was here I would look in the first
drawer find it post it find the password
49 percent of people still store some
passwords on the posted physical devices
like secure USBs or better but still you
know you're dependent on a small device
that you can lose that can be stolen
whatever and password managers well they
are two types either they are online
LastPass one-pass whatever and well you
know found average one big one gets
hacked every year so I'm sure your
passwords are secure and there the other
possibility is they're offline and I'm
sure you never had your laptop stolen or
destroyed and then lost all access to
any account so all those alternative
methods are there and they all have
flaws and password reuse is what a lot
of us are doing and has flaws but you
know just had to mention it okay so what
else what are the things we can do we
can put a salt a lot of people are doing
this right now just you know remember a
complex string of characters and just
vary the last few that was okay till now
there are attacks that are starting to
target those kind of passwords because
they're generally low entropy once you
know the salt so if I managed to get
your salt or like one or twice then I
figure out all your other passwords
there is very interestingly an algorithm
developed recently by Manuel Bloo now
seems he was the first one to really
think about this thing and say hey how
can I make an algorithm where I don't
need any physical device I don't need to
trust anyone else I just used my brain
and I don't have to remember
100 different passwords so I'll just use
some data some information local
information global information and make
that into a password system that I can
execute in my own brain
now that is groundbreaking there's just
a simple problem with the method which
is that room tested it on himself and
said I can make it work it works and so
I tried and I actually can't get it like
I have trouble understanding the
algorithm and I spent time on it so I'm
thinking having the standard for an
algorithm that is for public use be a
cheering Award winner can probably
execute it in his head that might not be
the right standard we want I mean
excellent work just not for us mortals
so there's a last possibility which is
full of promise which is pass phrases
pass phrases are just very long
passwords and people can remember them
very well and the problem is if your
password is 40 characters long most
websites won't accept that and like you
you have like they are slow to type so
the end result is oh that was not
supposed to be there sorry but the end
result is that we're stuck with
passwords and that well pass phrases
yeah that's just you know you probably
saw this comic before on the strength of
pass phrases versus passwords it's you
know like just using natural language
using our natural ability to remember
concept objects associate them is better
than our ability to remember small
variations on a simple word the end
thing is that we're stuck with passwords
for at least a while seems so how do we
do that how do we manage the Scourge
while being stuck with a scourge well we
with Ted there we decided to try to see
if we could improve on blooms work and
we thought you know there are
constraints for that what are the
constraints we want the passwords to be
secure that seems you know that's why
you have passwords high entropy and just
like entropy entropy like using the
right metrics for this your password
should resist attacks not only as a
password but also as a set of passwords
so if my managed to steal one of your
passwords or two of your passwords I
should still not easily get into your
other account that's the first thing
second thing is you should not forget
them you should have one method simple
method and it should be enough that if I
create a password today use the method
for other passwords with me my password
in three is it should be durable I
should not have lost everything yeah the
last next constraint is a bit targeted
but it should be easy to understand and
the last thing is it should be
compatible with frequent constraints if
someone asks you to put a Sumerian
character you should be able to put the
Sumerian character without changing your
algorithm because otherwise what happens
is that you say well I've got this
algorithm and just in case there's that
I have this algorithm and then instead
of having 100 passwords you have 100
password algorithms which are arguably
less efficient okay we have constraints
now what do we do with them we create a
big secret and we extract entropy we try
to just extract entropy in the form of
letters because the letters are
something that humans are relatively
good at and what's a large secret that
people can remember easily a sentence so
just use words and use small operation
on words to create a space word from a
sentence okay
from a high level view that's what you
need you need one passphrase high
entropy
we're generally talking at least six
words eight is best and like it's also
like you know what kind of words
but I'll get to that in the second half
of this talk
so one passphrase and one four-digit pin
it's not absolutely necessary but it's
much better to have before isn't it
there's four people with number of
problems there's actually a way out but
let's focus on this for now so that is
the main secret you have it's one
sentence and the number four digit
number should be enough to remember if
it's the only thing you use easier to
remember then like already three four
passwords okay but you need that is the
global information you need local
information otherwise any password you
create will be always the same or will
be random and so you need local
information and the local information is
what it's a four letter Q for each
website for example you know it could be
Facebook I could use face I could use
book I could use FC BK I choose but it
should be as easy as possible the
problem the goal is not making it secure
the goal is just making it remember and
well once we have this global
information and this local information
run a simple algorithm that extracts
digits what letters from the sentence
using the local information and the pin
seems simple enough I will start by
showing you an example because it's
always better with an example and this
is the example so it's called cute and
select so does this work it works a bit
okay so this is actually the whole
algorithm whole execution what do I have
I have my sentence my sentence here is
parallel ordinary very disastrous
divergent water just randomly chosen
words in a dictionary and I have my pin
six nine eight oh that is just you know
simple pin simple sentence
and I want to create a password for
Amazon so what do I do I create a queue
AMZN so far it's fine and I do the first
step first type is called Q I look for
the first lateral of my queue in the
sentence so I get to the first a then
it's called pin I take the first digit
of my pin and I go six letters further
PA so our al LEL I stop it l select I
select the next few letters I write them
down and now we're here and I look for
an M I we start the process cube and
select cube then select problem is their
answer there's isn't any m in the
sentence what do i do i look for the n
next letter in the alphabet but i don't
start from here i start from there i
find the end i go in nine letters
further and i write the next three okay
then i continue but this time i reached
the end and i cycle and we just do this
you do this four times as the name of
the algorithm says just q you find the
letter p' in you go and letters forward
select you write the next three and you
start from where you stopped okay
what like the algorithm is there a bit
ugly but it's basically it's just says
what i said at least six random words
random digits service name and this is
just executing the thing you run the
algorithm repeated four times the
finding the letter if the letter is not
in there you find the next one in the
alphabet and so on until you find the
letter you go forward cycling over and
you get the next three letters okay this
is Cuban select now I have it's maybe
understandable but is it secure is it
usable see security wise well first good
thing is route forcing it is hard
standards I've heard different numbers
but it's generally 36 to 42 bits from
what I've heard because online setting
means you get limited amount of tries
per second it's actually some the work
by bloom is actually assuming wave lower
numbers because services tend to block
your way earlier than that but still 36
42 bits is should be good enough and if
you just naively brute-force it like the
whole password space is technically any
12 character password with English
errors so it's 56 bits now weirdly
enough if you optimize it depending on
the distribution of trigrams in the
english corpus you only lose 4 bits
which you know as a surprise like that
it's actually quite uniform and so
attacking the password route force wise
we're high above the security threshold
attacking the passphrase well the
average length musics just impossible
but even dictionary attacks you know six
words each has more than 1015 bits of
entropy you're safe assuming the
adversary doesn't have additional
information okay so no brute force what
about clear text attacks because that's
the thing I wanted to find right I you
don't want someone just with no
information on you to be unable to
attack you also want someone who steals
some of your passwords and the problem
is that it's quite hard to analyze
because if we make that then the
adversary who has one clear text must
make lots of assumptions on the
distribution so let's just assume an
extremely strong adversary who instead
of knowing one clear text which is you
know for trigrams that are present in
your passphrase instead they know where
the trigrams are so they know the length
and they know the position and this is
actually very powerful for the adversary
because there is ambiguity the fourth
trigram we can actually show you don't
know whether it's before or after the
third trigram in the sentence like the
probability distribution is the same
generally the second is after the first
so you know that like relative positions
of both but the third and the fourth you
have no idea where they are like this
distribution goes all over the place so
the adversary knows a lot of additional
information now how can they do it with
its information well that is actually
residual entropy empirically speaking so
we consider in an anniversary with all
this information just randomly creates a
password you randomly create a password
give the password to the adversary and
check okay on the remaining passphrase
is how many are compatible with this
password and that's so attacking the
passphrase using the password and the
answer is well generally 50 bits so
generally with one clear text password
and additional information you still
have more security than someone could
try online there's actually very low
probability of getting over 40 bits like
it's something like three people out of
10,000 and I'll get to that it's a just
anomalous behavior but the question also
is why am I saying attacking the
passphrase because what you want is
attacking the password it turns out that
if you take a password generated with
this algorithm and you take another
password generated using this algorithm
well assuming one is a real password the
distribution on the other really looks
like the initial distribution the the
passwords are generally independent you
can get maybe two bits of information
using one password to get another so
using a clear text passwords we take
another clear text password doesn't work
using it to attack the passphrase is a
much more general attack that is
promising
but that actually doesn't really work in
practice like this is best-case scenario
for the attacker okay but that is one
one clear text password what happens
with two and with two and with three we
can see that actually there's a risk
well there is a risk there there is
there are a few people there's actually
one person whose password was entirely
guessable from three revealed clear
texts now can anyone guess why that is
why someone's password could be entirely
guessable using three to clear texts the
passphrase
no but the I but the same well it's
actually not that it was very very
stupid
well each time you reveal a clear text
password you reveal 12 letters right so
if you're lucky you reveal 24 letters
with two clear text 36 with three
assuming you're very lucky now some of
the passwords generated some of the pass
phrases where less than 36 letters so if
you're extremely lucky and you know the
position of all of this which is what a
normal address we shouldn't know but our
strong adversary knows well they just
have the whole sentence already shown
but normally there should be lots of
ambiguity on where the trigrams are so
that this is really a worst-case
analysis and so this worst-case analysis
shows that on average two plaintext
attacks you're still left with more than
20 bits so anniversary has to try around
1 million different pass phrases to get
your thing assuming they know what that
okay oh let's just go to just summarize
a little bit I think oh wait no there's
sorry there's a usability I did promise
usability we tried it we actually got 12
people to try it over 4 days so it would
be nice to have more but asking people
to actually use an algorithm multiple
times a day for a while is
hard on the uses so the thing is
initially people struggle with it I mean
initially the first two passwords they
generated they made mistakes and the
record was actually nearly four minutes
to create one password that's not
acceptable and we told them you know you
can use anything you want you can use a
pen and paper you can do whatever just
here has you create the passphrase you
create a password how much time do you
need and it was like 82 seconds now the
fun thing is after two days using
basically creating two in the morning
two in the afternoon not crazy intensive
training two days sped up by a hundred
percent down to 42 seconds average and
median is the same and then we decided
to get naughty with them and say you
can't use pen and paper anymore
you have to do everything in your head
and well once again everyone struggles
and goes back up some like more than
three minutes and then over the next day
go back down and everyone actually in
the end managed to get the password
entirely in their head under 60 seconds
and down to 24 seconds so someone
actually managed to get quite fast this
is those people made less than 16
different passwords so it still limited
training and they got faster now the
problem is you know some still took a
long time and when we asked them you
know would you use this somewhere like
you know it's just bit too expensive so
that's something you gotta work on but
it already is doable I mean with a bit
of training everyone could get under 45
seconds and get passwords that are I
showed secure there are a few things
that to be said though which is that it
doesn't follow all the constraints it
doesn't allow for a number of special
characters or length constraints or
frequent changes now the good thing is
that you can actually handle all of this
very very
you just decide once and for all I'm
gonna use one as my number and like I
don't know pounds as my special
character put it in the middle of your
password and sure it doesn't add any
security but it makes it follow the
constraints and it's deterministic so
you always create the same now length
constraints if you want it to be longer
you can just add whatever you want at
the end as long as it's always the same
thing
you can run one more round of Cupid
select and if it's the other way around
well you should be a bit worried I know
my bank doesn't allow passwords for more
than 6 characters and I don't use online
banking a lot as a consequence so you
know you you there are risk with that
but it basically depends on the service
if the service you're using is
fundamentally an unsecure you can't make
a secure password for it the last thing
is frequent changes and you can address
this quite easily too
by just changing the queue so you let's
say I start with Facebook like queue for
facebook will be face and I say okay I
need to change it every three months
because I work at Facebook and they ask
me to change my password frequently like
I don't work for Facebook but let's say
they do that well I say okay I'll just
add one to the queue every three months
so for example instead of Facebook I'll
just say G b.c.e instead of FAC II just
increase the letters by one and that's
actually enough to change your whole
password entirely if you're lucky
changing one character the first
character changes the rest of the
password entirely and if you're unlucky
you need to so frequent changes lengths
constraints number and special
characters we can handle that's a good
news so what's left well just show you
something which is 50 C 2 bit security
passwords guaranteed resistance against
single kill text attack probable
resistance against up to 3 you can
create lots of passwords with this
like I actually ran some things before
having like that suppose it were too
similar you can at least have 500 and if
you're a bit careful with how you design
your cues basically yeah just being a
bit careful not making two cues that are
identical then you're okay
and quick learning process according to
the models which say Moses everyone else
uses everyone should remember this and
we actually tested it by not showing the
users their sentence again and we were
expecting you know a few to forget which
happens and actually on the second day a
single user forgot a single word so like
they memorize the sentence entirely on
the first day well except one user so
like more Merrill than we thought
natural extension to handle frequency
constraints there's another extension to
improve security to make it like more
durable in the future if we won't but
that's it there's a problem well not a
problem but one thing I didn't mention
which is the passphrase and that's the
second part how do we choose a
passphrase if your passphrase is to be
or not to be that is the question then
any password you create no matter the
algorithm will be insecure and there's a
reason I chose to be or not to be that
is the question because there was
recently a study on that where they
asked people to create pass phrases and
like remember them and use them and in
one study of about a thousand people
being asked to just create something
2.54 53% of the users chose that one
and even in studies where they asked
people please please do it something
that is relevant to you and that no one
else does and like make it personal and
everything people still used famous
sentences quotes from books whatever
there was not a single study so there
was a single study where people did not
have they they did not get a collision
between two users on choosing a sentence
and it was those were long sentences and
the single study that did actually one
at least one person had to be or not to
be but they were the only one who got it
so that was fine and another one son
found another quote but they were the
only one
so people were a bit more distributed
but you just you still had a lot of the
sentences that were present in the other
studies it just had too few people to
actually check it out so how do we
choose a passphrase well I said first
possibility choose them oh it was 2.5 55
I was off by 0.1 0.0 1% you know people
choose that they choose sentence
servants from the literature actually
you can show that even if you take a
sentence uniformly written from like
chosen from any book created in the
history of mankind it's still low
entropy i people really overestimate the
amount of but come on this author is
obscure know like it's present it's on
the internet it's too late unless it's
your written manuscript but that is
unpublished it's not safe so if we let
people choose them people choose them
very badly
even when you try to push them to prime
them into getting stuff that is secure
well what if you impose them randomly
well we all remember randomly imposed
passwords and those work very well so
memorably twice it doesn't work we all
forget them and there's another thing
which is if you have a six words
sentence and you want people to remember
it if there are words in the sentence
that the people don't know then they
probably will have out of trouble so if
you want to use a big dictionary you
have a high probability of getting a
rare word in it and the people won't
know it and so you can't use a large
dictionary so actually if you have a
random generation you're more or less
forced to either have strong memory
problems or
a very hard memory issues so we decided
well what if we try to take the best of
both Wells and the idea is very simple
you take a list of words that is
randomly generated and you ask people to
choose from it it's as simple as that
you show them we did that just two
groups to check it out of bits
20 to 100 words like 20m or a hundred
words they had to pick and remember six
and we were wondering you know what what
made them choose those words and how
does that affect entropy of the
sentences generated and you know what
kind of mistakes they make and does that
actually help the memorization because
you know that if we want to use that
method to create pass phrases it better
help the entropy and it better help the
memory otherwise it's all for naught
well ah protocol was very simple showed
them the list of words from a large
dictionary this little dictionary was
actually we took the hundred thousand
most frequent words in like Google and
grams and restricted it to actual
English words so it's still like eighty
six thousand seven hundred and thirteen
if I'm correct around that anyway okay
we asked to choose six words or four
control-group wind post them just give
them the six words to generate it in
same way ask them to type it so that
they remember it show them in the
sentence again as them to memorize it do
a few exercises to make sure the
memorize it and then well that would be
too easy it's still fresh in their
memory so I mean we're just we're not
testing any kind of long-term memory we
were just testing short-term memory so
let's distract them and to distract them
we actually had a fun task which was
show them the list of words that other
and other user had and they try they
were trying to guess which words the
other one chose because that actually
did two things in one
the first is that it distracted them
they were looking at lots of other words
probably forgetting their own but the
second is maybe there was a method
behind how users chose their words a
method we were blind to maybe there was
a single algorithm that everyone use and
we just work differently or couldn't
think of our thinking maybe if someone
repeatedly manages to guess all the
words the other people choose the method
is bad so just ask people to guess and
see if they do anything better than
uniform like random luck and and then we
ask them to write their initial sentence
again and if they fail we ask them to
write it while giving them their initial
list of words just to see if that helps
so the the thing is also that yeah the
distractor they could do multiple times
so they could spend a while on it and
what happens with that oh this is the
sentence like this is an example it's a
bit big this is the hundred word list
and you see there's everything there's a
chat book there's a planetesimal and
there's off you really have words of all
complexities now what were we expecting
we were expecting people to choose words
that were more familiar with I mean I'm
guessing that if you have to choose
words in there you might take hazards
that's a nice word when I take coach you
might not want to take pyrophosphate or
apolipoproteins
why not some of you might but you know
you might still be slightly biased in
favor of frequent words or words you're
familiar with then you know there are
three main ways that people could choose
a uniform that's great people choose
words uniformly blindly they don't care
about the semantic value they don't care
about the syntactic value they just take
every words with equal probability and
we have all the entropy we could want
and that is really not realistic
other thing that was the one we were
afraid of
they take the words that are the most
frequent so I only look at the very most
frequent word in the list and I choose
them and that's it and if I do that
actually the entropy drops I did I get
nearly new advantage from the method and
the last possibility is quite natural
it's a you know basically a words
probability to get chosen is
proportional to the probability of it
being chosen in natural language like in
a big corpus you basically if I show you
the 100 word list you take a word in it
as frequently as you use it when you
speak or when you write on
proportionally speaking at least so
those are the three methods we could
figure out and what and yeah let's yeah
those let's look at the data first this
is how they chose the words in the
twenty world group so we actually showed
them twenty words and the this is a for
English speakers and foreign like
language speakers people whose who were
not native speakers and we were afraid
that all the mass would be in there that
would be bad for us that would lower the
entropy a lot but it turns out well no
even among the rare very rare words like
the rarest in the group we give them
they still pick them and they still pick
them at reasonable rates it's not
uniform but it's pretty good and what
happens if I show them even more words
well they have even more choice they're
probably even more biased it is true but
those are buckets so basically this is
corresponding to the twenty most
frequent words there's a lot of mass but
if you actually look about twenty
percent of the words chosen our among
the half of the dictionary that is the
least used and this is a big dictionary
so
just yeah just see the relative thing
one is a bit more biased than the other
but it's not that biased and what does
it mean for the entropy well it means
that it means sorry that the curves look
like this now this was the one the big
pink one is the one we were afraid of
this is basically we show you a set of
words and you take the smallest one you
take the most frequent ones and that
would have been very bad because
basically an a method is like it's
better if it's closer to a straight line
so this was our worst analysis like a
worst hypothesis was smallest 20 we show
you 20 words you take the most frequent
ones and that's not the case at all
but it's actually even better than that
because if we show you the 100 most
frequent words you know you're not
taking them according to the natural
language bias which is the blue curve
there you're taking them according to a
much smaller corpus so if I show you a
hundred words what you do is actually
you look at 30 and you pick among those
30 according to your natural language
bias and if I show you 20 words you pick
something like 16 15 and choose among
those now what this means is that
entropy wise it's quite amazing because
here is the just that the summary of the
entropies uniform over the general whole
dictionary is the idea we can't do
better than that
and it's 16 point 42 bits now the worst
case is the most frequent like the
smallest 100 I think the most frequent
words in all the things I've been shown
and I'm at like 10 point 7 bits per word
so like there's a big difference and
if I actually let people choose assuming
they choose like natural corpus bias
it's actually half the ideal optimal
entropy so you need sentences that are
twice as long to get the same amount of
security and now what happens with the
different things we tried well our worst
guess for how people choose is corpus 30
and we're at fifteen point ninety two
bits or at ninety eight percent of the
entropy of uniform choice with while
letting people choose so we take a two
percent dip in entropy the question is
is it worth it
memory ones people are nearly as secure
but is it worth it and that's the thing
those are the mistakes and so two
sections the first time we asked them in
the second time we showed them the list
of words except to the control who
didn't have a list of words now only
about half the people got it right in
the one hundred word group but most of
the mistakes actually came from making a
typo pluralizing a words adding an ING
or that kind of thing there were a few
who forgot one two three words but if
you look at the error rate it's quite
fun the number of forgotten words goes
from 16 to 31 between the 100 word group
in the control group the control group
is actually half the size so the rate at
which people forget was is four times
the radius which people mistake the
order of words six times higher to make
variance it's 2 times no it's four times
higher wrong words like just something
that has no relationship once again six
times higher so the effective memory is
actually quite present now arguably this
is quite short-term memory but there is
a distractor task to make it harder and
like the effect is on the control group
there is another thing that I must say
which is you know the control group
spent less time they spent less time
looking at was less time making their
sentences of
course they're going to be worse at
remembering them but actually if we look
within the two other groups the people
who spent longer on it didn't get any
better there is no correlation between
time spent making the sentence and the
errors made and that was weird
but it actually shows that the control
group the difference in memorization
might be relevant well seems very
relevant because if the time taken does
not affect it then the argument that the
control group is disadvantaged doesn't
hold so okay we've got better
memorization and better entropy on
choosing which words but what about the
structure of the sentence I mean we
showed semantic effects but not
syntactic effects because maybe everyone
is doing word objective verb adverb
found objective and that reduces the
entropy quite a lot once again so you
know just looking at this what happens
and the thing is people don't really
take tend to make meaningful sentences a
few really made very meaningful
sentences quite fun ones of that but on
average about 50 percents we couldn't
find any meaning any global meaning but
the thing is that the structures they
used like the organization noun adverb
65 of the 99 sentence well passphrases
made were unique and 65 were unique even
according to very very limited things so
to determine the uniqueness we only had
four categories now verbs adjectives
adverbs and like the others which
counted is like okay for everything so
if we were not sure about one words
value we just counted it for everything
so this is actually a low order like a
lower bound and there was a single
single structure that was present more
than three times and that was all nowt
and that could be annoying but actually
you see this is the distribution there's
just one bias towards having more verbs
in the central position that's the only
bias we could see and the bias that of
course nouns are much more frequent but
when you actually look at the fact that
nouns form about 60% of the English
dictionary the fact that about 60% of
the words chosen announce is okay and
the fact that some people choose all
nouns is still okay because it's the
most like the biggest category so it
doesn't really reduce the entropy by
that much and it's still you know not
even 10% of people who did that okay
ah so I've got these methods people get
98 percent of the entropy at least they
get better memorability
and it seems that syntactically speaking
they're fine okay and we're literally
but that's fine so to conclude well okay
97 to 98 actually 20 word list yet 20
like gets 99 percent but it has lower
memorization gains so let's use that but
there's something else we can use a
bigger dictionary and that's the thing
like that's actually there if I use a
uniform over 10,000 was a lot of online
dictionaries that give you random words
have between five and ten thousand and
estimates on the size of our faculty
vary but you know they they they they
vary but still from 20,000 onwards you
start having words that you don't know
not all of them but still some so if you
use a uniform sampling over a limited
dictionary you get thirteen point three
bits per word if you let people choose
from a limited set you get sixteen
so you casually
gain entropy by letting people choose
because letting them choose over a
bigger dictionary more than compensates
for the fact that they are biased that's
that's the thing they're bias is way
lower than the game okay so ah
it's memorable and it's lightweight the
whole thing can hold in less than two
megabytes which still a lot but I mean
you can run it in the browser and the
main reason why you want to do that
is that you want the word list to be
generated by the user locally it's like
you can download it on your telephone
you can just put it in your browser
whatever it's small enough that it's a
lightweight tool and okay so this is
just very simple tool to create pass
phrases of high quality and there are a
few questions on what you can do with it
which is for example what's the optimal
number hunt hundred is a lot people
might be a bit just anxious to see that
many words and might be paralyzed maybe
you could have a bit less is it
interesting to take bigger dictionaries
so we use the dictionary that's like a
third of the like the most frequent
third of the English language we could
get you know two three about two more
bits of entropy if we increased it but
is it worth it I don't know and that is
actually quite a fun thing which is some
languages have really smaller
vocabularies in English like about an
order of magnitude less and in this case
you can select and the space race choice
become more complex because you know
Esperanto is got a small vocabulary you
might not want to use pass phrases in
Esperanto there are a few people who
speak only Esperanto so that's still
okay and you know like one fun question
which is how do people choose their
words we can show that it's not
according to semantic bias well not very
much so we looked at positional bias
we're on the page they choose their
words turns out it's not really that
there's a small bias for the ones closer
to where they type small buyers for the
first line but that's it it's like
barely noticeable 10% higher than the
average and well we did some other work
in this direction we actually just found
a typo tolerant password which is quite
weird because you want the hash to be
compatible there's very good work on
that by chatterjee on like do you want
to correct typos on your password
automatically and if so how do you do it
and there's you know outcomes of this
work like codes that are culturally
neutral that's where you start
culturally neutral because when it comes
to e-voting you don't want one part of
the population having a higher error
rate than the rest but there is some
research that i'm quite excited to do
and it's a better attack model for Cuban
select because you know our adversary is
extremely strong because we have the
assumption that they know where the bits
are and any weaker thing it might not be
universal enough to compensate for all
adversaries but the big thing is we want
like that's that's the main work we're
trying to do right now which is Cuban
select is still expensive
some people take nearly six sixty
Seconds even though the average is lower
and we would like to make it popular
that can sense it anyone can use it but
for that we probably need to hit the
thirty second barrier if I give you an
password algorithm that you can use in
thirty second you might use it if I say
60 second it becomes costly and the
thing is anytime you modify the
algorithm for Cuban select you don't
know how it will behave you know how it
will be for hey Vaughn the security wise
that's a simple analysis but you don't
know whether people will manage to do it
so how do we create alternatives well
the first bad news is that all the
local area around Cuban selectors that
if you add more words add more letters
choose four groups of three or four or
three groups of four
every time either is a usability drops
or the security drops so much
that's your debt that liked it you get
ten bits of security against the clear
text and that's it so how do we find
better alternatives to keep it select
well the best way well one way would be
to have a lot of money and run thousands
of user experiments which would be nice
that's not what we do so the other way
is well can we actually get a cost a
cost model for all those operations
because I mean if we want 30 seconds you
don't have time for many operations all
your algorithms will be very simple and
well as always bloom got there first but
I actually don't really like manual
blooms assumptions because he said that
basically taking the seventeenth letter
in the alphabet takes about as much time
as the first experimentally that's not
true if I ask people here to get the
seventeenth letter they would take about
probably twice as much time as if I ask
for the eighth letter and quite a lot
more than for the first so there's a
dimension of automatic learning and just
properly like proximate algorithms so
what we're doing right now is actually
we've got an experiment launched where
we are asking people to do lots of small
operations in different orders to figure
out which ones are costly which ones are
free can we use modulo can we use small
multiplication can we use all this and
hopefully we can bound give lower bounds
for mental algorithms and really
hopefully the lower bounds are low
enough that we can use that to create a
better alternative well thank you and
that's it
you